tv and on booktv.org
playwright and director david mahmet
presents a criticism of his one-time
liberal ideologies and opines on several
current political and social issues next
on book tv
mr momet delivers the 2012 manhattan
institute's wriston lecture at the plaza
hotel in new york city it's a little
over an hour
[Applause]
what a magnificent introduction thank
you very much to paul thank you to larry
moan and thank you all here tonight i
was thinking about harold pinter who was
a friend of mine rest in peace
and harold
when he accepted the nobel prize wrote a
rather scathing indictment of the west
and
i
i thought back to what i was making a
movie with harold and we were shooting
in white chapel or as the jews of his
era called the vitajepel
in london a jewish neighborhood and he
started reminiscing about his life
growing up over his uncle morty's radio
shop
yeah he was
harold pinter was reminiscing over
growing up over his uncle morty's radio
shop in the jewish area of white chapel
and his magnificent
radioactive voice
became
yiddish and went back to 1938
and
his face lit up remembering those days
growing up in the warmth of the the
jewish ghetto of london and i thought
how can harold pinter
whom i did and do revere
denigrate the west when if it weren't
for the united states he and every other
jew in london would have been killed
i thought that was kind of odd and
i was remembering the intersection of
his political views and
his cultural upbringing and then i
remembered thinking when harold first
started writing about politics i was a
young writer maybe in my 20s he was
probably 50 something and i thought
isn't that a shame that this wonderful
writer has turned into an old man and
all he can do is write about politics
because his powers
[Applause]
well
ha ha
and but i think what happens you know
that one of our other great philosophies
philosophers was hudi ledbetter
better known as lead belly a great great
poet who said in one of his songs that
he'd done is fighting his hoop collar
and crying and he commenced to studying
about the great long time
so that's i kind of think what i've been
doing in the last few years is trying to
commence the studying about the great
long time and just as harold did to go
from thinking about the most minute of
humor in human interactions is
two lines of dialogue to thinking about
what the hell's going on here
and so uh
i wrote this here speech
okay
so the the the 2012 emmys began with a
predictable round of jokes about
republicans including an exhortation to
applaud the fact that there were no
republicans in hollywood or any must be
in hiding or be very lonely indeed
my question was what in the world did
this partisan humor
have to do with a trade show
particularly with a trade show beholden
in every moment in every way
to capitalism to a medium developed to
flog goods by the sale of which
those at the emmys made their living and
what of the barn owl
i quote from the catalogue of an old
revered american clothing company
that branched out into selling
knickknacks naturally sustainable white
poplar barn owl environmentally friendly
and organic based paint reclaimed glass
eyes base made of a reclaimed horseshoe
well very well and good but who in the
world needs a barn owl
and what is this owl the composition of
which should obsess us
what is the reason behind this
compulsivity
it is the continual proclamation that
self-government is unnecessary that one
need not apply reason or restraint or
courage in the making of difficult
decisions that one need only spout the
party line but that one must do it
continually
a group of celebrities lately did a
television ad in which they pledged
allegiance to obama this may differ in
degree but not in kind from any fascist
salute and when in the world did we
begin in this country pledging
allegiance to human beings
the
i brought this along because joe kiernan
and his daughter wrote this great book
your teacher said what this is what my
child my 13 year old brought home from
public school
are you a democrat or a republican on
gun control a democrat wants to restrict
the number and amount of guns a
republican wants to allow guns to buy
citizens without restriction on the
environment the democrat wants to make
factories reduce pollution restrict
drilling for oil and national park lands
and a republican wants not to pass
pollution laws that would cost factories
money this is in a public school if
that's not taxation without
representation i know it is
that that the exhortations of the left
are unreasonable and inconsistent
ensures that no one will adopt them
accidentally because of their utility
they are thus a perfect pledge of
allegiance but their lack of reason
ensures that they must be continually
repeated as such
and that every possible instance or
occasion
be introduced by a protestation of faith
or an anathema of the other side
should the leftist omit the obsessive
incantations
the repressed which is doubt might
actually actually accidentally intrude
see also the marine recruit who is or
was
drilled to begin each sentence each
response with sir
lest as he was instructed he had denned
an invitation to offer himself for sex
this was noted by the psychologist
declare ambo in 1921 and known as
declare
syndrome where here the individual
overcome by authority is shocked into
compulsive confession of his willingness
to submit
as with house guests and strangers one
of the liberal community is continually
taxed with establishing his bona fides
in a happy family or work environment or
a religious organization a community in
short one may relax this inquisition and
get on with the communal tasks this is
the most immediate effect of the benefit
of community and from this the other
benefits flow
and accepting community standards and
committing oneself to their propagation
one trades some potential freedom of
action
we are not going to let the kids grow up
and choose or i am going to make a
commitment i consider myself a citizen
of the world as an example of one who
won't respect
won't accept responsibility
in a community one trades some freedom
of action for increased security in the
moment and true community members share
certain basic assumptions and so their
behavior is more predictable they may
violate community standards but the
penalty which is excommunication shame
or ostracism is clear and costly and so
transgression of the norms is more
restricted
but time with strangers must constantly
be spent establishing the limits of
intimacy
our most compact social unit is the
family and functions almost completely
in modes of behavior so long and
definitely established that they become
unconscious
in the family how one greets praises
reprimands apologizes lies demands
complains these forms though unconscious
are to the family familiar completely
known and completely clear and the
inclusion of even the most beloved of
house guests shatters the ease of the
family interaction and the knowledge
previously consigned to the unconscious
mind must be brought to mind to the
conscious explained altered or suspended
for the benefit of the guest
which is wise mr franklin told us fish
and visitors begin to stink after three
days
the
the toll and energy is huge
tolstoy says that you know when a
marriage is falling apart as the husband
and wife's conversation
progresses logically
he was one smart jew
[Applause]
it's impossible to convene even the
smallest and most transitory of human
groups without them improvising if they
cannot discover a social structure which
is to say a culture
culture grows in mysterious ways and its
growth has nothing to do with reason
is it reasonable for example that all
americans
have to say
what seems to be the trouble officer
[Laughter]
where is it written or that they have to
say hi we can't come to the phone right
now but if you leave your name and
number
where in the world are these forms
prescribed
a culture extemporizes itself in
observances in response to communal
necessity to deal with which it also
extemporizes myths
these myths no less than political views
or modes of organization can derive only
from
the limited recurring number of human
problems and human solutions
the left's discovery of
global warming the sinful the sinfulness
of man causing the seas to rise and so
destroy humankind may also be found in
genesis 6.
and consider the taking of snapshots
before the shutters click the
photographer says one two three
why
well here's why i think in the first
days of portrait photography and
exposure could last up to three minutes
so the sitters heads were mobilized by a
brace because they couldn't move or else
the shot would be foggy they were
instructed to stay perfectly still and
as the three minutes started to end the
photographer would reassure them almost
done one two three now we're done
contemporary cameras can take a snapshot
of one thousandth of a second but still
the photographer says one two three why
because photographers have always said
one two three but now the phrase is
uttered before the shot
and if asked why the photographer might
say to allow the subject to compose
himself but why does the subject need to
compose himself this makes every amateur
portrait the lifeless same the subjects
face
having adopted that self-same i am now
getting my picture taken
in the original photos
in the original photos the sitters
looked still and stirred and had to hold
still and the contemporary posed shots
every one of us looks like a fool
not only is exposure instantaneous
there's no need for stillness but it
persists and turns without thought and
seemingly without human intervention
from the useful to the residuals and the
destructive
cities each have their own culture in
san francisco a greeting to a stranger
is likely to be returned and new york
ignored and in los angeles responded to
with frigid rage
likewise of course there's our beautiful
american culture it can be found most
readily in our jokes puns or illusions
in the illusions of stand-up comedy and
television commercials our television
commercials the lowest denominator of
culture of course and thus they are the
most powerful and cohesive here's a
great television commercial we saw at
the super bowl there's a holocaust of
some time a city is buried in rubble
later tough trucks of the manufacturer's
brand emerge one by one from the rubble
and the drivers get out to congratulate
each other all glad to be alive and have
having had the wisdom to purchase so
great a truck and one survivor says to
another have a twinkie
so what do we have here but an allusion
to a magnificent american myth an urban
legend taken from the very schoolyard
where we've told each other for 50 years
twinkies have a shelf life of 10 million
years
so why might people buy the truck
because in enjoying the illusion
enjoying the commonality they were
united in the most heavy of experiences
which is belonging
the left ridicules the notion of culture
and enshrines intellect to them it's
logic that all things it's logical that
all things may be reasoned through
and that if we were just sufficiently
intelligent to choose more intelligent
leaders all the age-old problems must
disappear
but in the celebration of omnipotent
intellect we citizens become as those
house guests dedicated to figure
figuring out how a family works
and how first of all to refrain from
offending each other out goes patriotism
religion free enterprise freedom of
conscience free exercise of legal rights
which anyone
takes the soapbox and alleges might
offend out in short goes to culture but
now we are stymied because we don't know
how to replace those practices so a new
culture is improvised speak to no one at
the airport ride for 12 hours across the
uh uh
uh across the ocean and don't introduce
yourself don't talk to anybody on the
elevator keep your mouth shut because
anything might offend alter your speech
in response to any suggestion that it
might offend and demand from all a
fealty to the one uniting power the new
culture whose champion is the left for
you yourself as you know without a
culture are alone and confused and lost
the obama campaign's 2008 change may
thus be understood as a directive
the whole of which is change or suffer
shall you stand up or sit down when the
star-spangled banner is sung shall you
sing or not should a man open a door for
a woman is it permitted for whites to
criticize a failed politician if he's
black are terrorists entitled to the
same protections enjoyed by citizens
should folks of the same sect be allowed
to marry has he or she replaced he is
the correct pronoun they're
operationally the same question as they
create fear as the questioner has no
idea where to look for guidance or
clarification
just like the house guest and the host
locked in the least terminal of the
discussions the exist the insistence on
deference in all things
the mutual desire to express courtesy
driving both sides mad
this fear of a cultural vacuum is filled
historically by the spontaneous
emergence of two aides a leader in an
enemy
the culturally unsettled need a strong
man someone unquestionably superior to
themselves in the vision and intellect
and thus deserving that allegiance which
will replace the structure sacrificed in
the cultures abandonment this is the
tsar so beloved of the left lennon marx
freud castro stalin hitler karzar enemy
director of bisexual trans gay lesbian
questing and queer studies someone in
whom one can believe in in the midst of
quote the mess we have inherited which
was previously known as the united
states of america
i see also jim jones sun young moon
bernie madoff and all those claiming by
intellect or faith they can supervene
the natural laws
if there were such a thing as historical
necessity why in the world would we have
to aid it
must one not question at least the sense
of proportion of a human being who
proclaimed they will say that under us
the seas cease to rise
these
ideologues opportunist opportunists
visionaries quacks and thugs seem to
lead but as per tulsa they actually
emerge from and ride for power impelled
by
the mass confusion of the unbalanced
group
the political impulse to submission for
all that is explained as more reasonable
than outmoded forms representative
government religion and culture
may also be seen
a lie to the impulse by those in
extremists that seek out magic
the client of the psychic healer and
energy therapist bloodless surgeon past
life's therapist and the worshiper of
the political strongman each trade
autonomy for magic
but the power the magic feathers the
magic beans the stimulus like the
resurrection of tinkerbell cannot be
attempted without sacrifice hear the
sacrifice of reason the contemporary
equivalent of gashing the flesh to make
it rain
sacrifice of course implies a
supernatural recipient indeed an angry
god and it requires an intercessor a
strong man a priest perhaps a demigod
himself to teach us the acceptable forms
the political dupe may be questioned by
his non-afflicted brother to induce
reasons why the failed politician
the incipient dictator the flim-flam man
the pretender to godhood should be
supported when his words are meaningless
his promise is either encoded or failed
and his worth word proved worthless but
this misses the point
for as with the psychic healer it is not
the promised result of submission for
which the afflicted is paying but for
the experience of a submission itself
which is a real of transitory cure for
his anxiety
the victim of the mystic healer is kept
in the fold by promises the treatment
will work but it will take more money
more time or belief than previously
suspected and the victim of the
demagogue quizzical about the failure of
his idol to accomplish anything promised
is also school indeed self school that
the magic just needs time to work the
disease was worse than previously
imagined and to suggest otherwise is not
only illogical but in pious
he this political dupe just like the
object of an intervention can affect any
residual doubt as rage onto those who
are trying to help him
this may be understood as demonic as
they seem to require both his depos
apostasy and his psychic dissolution
the exercise of total faith is that
benefit for which the leftist has paid
with his autonomy
its merest weakening is to him equal to
psychological death consider it leaves
him alone
for if deprived by doubt of his
essential identity with the believing
group he's also of course deprived of
potential community with its opponents
whom he has just recently denounced as
the devil
and man is a social animal so no prodigy
of sophistry is too great nor too
embarrassing to those threatened with
this stranding
president obama they say fell apart on
television because he is when used to
the altitude in denver he was
unresponsive as to who have answered
back would have granted him as an uppity
negro this is the president of the
united states see also the absolutely
autonomic emergence in the liberal
community and the spanish spontaneous
sequential adoption of excuses for his
failure look at the mess he inherited
you just oppose him because he's a black
man any program needs time the system
itself is broken the job's too big for
one man and finally you know what
they're all the same
we human beings are lonely and that's
why we're interested in life on other
planets in past lives
and in politics
that's why we fantasize about and adopt
small groups gays blacks palestinians
the handicapped as totems this in
addition to an expression of legitimate
humanitarian concerns is the delightful
fantasy that these groups are compressed
by difficulties into a magnificent pure
unity unavailable to the mass
we the larger polity imagine them in
fact as tribes which is to say exotics
enjoying all the benefits of that gift
of culture which we in the larger group
have wished away
these tribes we feel possessed to
perfection those two things the victim
of anomie seeks in his political
subjugation communal purpose and an
enemy
the left names this enemy
big business the corporations the one
percent the homophobe the rich the jews
america this enemy is necessary not
because the troubles are hateful
but because they're weakened they've
become weak through the constant
intolerable
expenditure of energy in the
improvisation of a culture
like the strangers on a cruise
perpetually bantering
a house guest in what was previously his
own country the leftist who has quite
literally pledged allegiance to obama
fears that his most
precious possession belief may encounter
a rational challenge either from himself
or from another which is insurmountable
and that his faith then must fail
but the priceless appearance of a foul
fiend can enliven his resolve calling
not upon his exhausted belief but upon
his inexhaustible courage
i would suggest the beleaguered leftist
reimagines himself as horacious at the
bridge but that poem universally read in
the public schools of my youth is no
longer of cultural currency
and which of the songs of my youth
remain casey at the bat colombia the gem
of the ocean captain my captain the
star-spangled banner of the lord's
prayer the kaddish the communion the
mass the deacons one horseshade the
bible the declaration of independence
the gettysburg address
those various productions of poetry
universally read 50 years ago are
replaced in the brave new worlds
brave new world by slogans and the
reduction of debatable propositions to
commands celebrate diversity for example
where once we did not exhort but
practice the celebration of its polar
opposite unity the exhortation still
appearing on our coins
english literature until the late
mid-century was largely elusive it
assumed a common knowledge of the bible
the gospels the constitution the works
of shakespeare and various poems poets
of that region of time
there was that called poetry still
written today but i defy anyone here to
quote one line read as recently as last
week
and yet we remember for our entire lives
that which moved us not by command or by
appeal to the intellect but by resonance
with the soul which is as opposed to
political beliefs we all share a member
of the oliver wendell holmes poem the
one horse shea
have you heard of the wonderful one
horse shea that was built in such a
logical way it ran a hundred years to
the day and then of a sadness day
i'll tell you what happened without
delay scaring the person into fits
frightening the people out of their wits
have you heard of that i say and that he
goes on to characterize how it all fell
apart in one instant after 100 years and
it ends
you'll see of course if you're not a
dunce it went to pieces all at once all
at once and nothing for first just as
bubbles do when they burst
oliver wendell holmes wrote that at
night uh 1858 and in 1972 sir john globb
a british historian wrote a
pamphlet
called the fate of empires 1972 and he
wrote that the great empires
assyria persia greece the roman the arab
empires the ottoman empire spain russia
britain each flourished for around 250
years and this seems to be the space
allotted for imperial hegemony too long
a period of power
leads to decadence and that as the
family goes from shirt sleeves to shirt
sleeves in three generations so the
empire goes from the pioneers to the
innovators to the bureaucrats from
exploration on exploitation to decadence
the quest for world approval the welfare
state and squabbles over inheritable
inherited wealth and the notable feature
he writes of the declining nations is
the loss of physical energy
glob suggests as does the bible that the
state as a human organism is no
different than the family
both recapitulate human individual
tendencies and like the like the
individual human evolve and predictable
directions the human might indeed lead
live to be 120 years but no longer and
will decay through predictable stages as
will the family however wealthy and and
the state
however powerful and now we see we in
america are at the outward end of uh sir
john gloves 250 years and we see the
signs posited by glob
we've passed through the ages of
outburst conquest commerce commerce
affluence intellect and we've come to
the age of decadence this in all empires
he writes can be identified by
defensiveness pessimism materialism
frivolity the welfare state the
dissolution of the armed forces the
weakening of religion and the attempt to
curry favor in the world
but he also wrote a companion essay
called the search for survival in which
he writes that every one of us can
contribute to the recovery of our
country by working harder by fostering a
sense of comradeship and good work
and that only a revival of spiritual
devotion
not fashionable isms can inspire
selfless service and each of us can
contribute
by leading moral and dedicated lives
and by speaking and writing in that
sense and if we have no leaders we must
go it alone
in the chicago public schools we
regularly read the lay of the last
minstrel
horatius of the bridge
and perhaps as in horatius of the bridge
it is not quite the time to ask how can
man die better than by facing fearful
odds for the ashes of his fathers in the
temple of his gods perhaps that time is
not quite yet
but it's evident that the time for
sacrifice for the sake of the country
and the judeo-christian values in which
it was founded is near
the left's insistent on the absolute
primacy of their notions regarding
abortion birth control sex education
sterilization and gay rights
in looking at these we might be reminded
again that tolstoy reminds us the first
visible signals of a change are often
mistaken for the mode of force
the bow wave which we see first
is the most apparent but does not impel
the ship the smoke which we see first is
the most apparent but does not impale
the locomotive
the shibulus of the left similarly seem
to be the championship of various causes
taken in total however an independent of
protestation they call for a lowering of
the birth rate which is one of the first
in a universal sign of national decline
see also the attendant call from the
left for the lowering or abolition of
the requirements for citizenship the
left would say the traditional
definitions of such are an egregious
example of american exceptionalism which
is to say arrogance that we are
first citizens of the world but
citizenship implies defined rights and
obligations
what rights does an american have in
north korea around china or for that
matter in indonesia and what rights does
an american jew gay or a woman enjoy in
syria what obligations do we have to the
french nation to suggest where citizens
of the world destroys our understanding
of the term and so weakens us in the
performance of the duties of a citizen
one might say that the apogee of
american power was the 1969 moon landing
and since then we the most successful
empire in history according to greatest
access to prosperity happiness and
public life in history have been in a
decline
this decline has given told us is
inevitable nothing lasts forever this
period of diminishing american hegemony
however may be one of healthy age
we citizens are the owners of its
country and its board of directors and
we may find the strength to reasonably
consider the options open to us in this
confusing time none of them is perfect
and this is a sign we must make a moral
choice which is to say a choice between
two flawed or indeed bad alternatives if
we do not choose the choice will be made
for us by those interested at home and
abroad in weakening the power of the
american electorate
it's not a brave announcement that our
country's imperfect none of the works of
man is perfect but it is our country to
govern to defend and to enjoy as long as
we choose to set our minds to it thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
i think we're going to have a few
questions
so uh
there are two
people with microphones
uh raise your hand and please wait for
the microphone and we'll try to get as
to as many people as you possibly can
jim we'll start here all right jim
pearson i'm jim pearson uh mr mammoth
thank you very much for that thoughtful
address thank you
uh
let me ask you a question about
hollywood culture with which you began
your address
and it's always been political to some
degree in the 1950s we had ronald reagan
and adolf monjou
the hollywood ten
today we have robert redford barbara
streisand
so
you described the culture what is the
dynamic in your opinion that drives it
to the left
and is are there any signs perhaps maybe
in your own career
uh by which it might be redirected
before it brings us all down like the
one horse shay
well you know you know in in in my
racket of show business and particularly
in hollywood we're fantasists
if you if you look at the people who are
championing
trying to save the world various movie
stars we're trying to save it in you
know in the 30s and 40s you know the the
phrase in hollywood was breeze there a
man with soul so dead he was not in the
30s red okay so the fantasists in the
30s and the fantasies and the 40s and
the fantasies today are
are saving the world in every movie it
makes sense that they're going to start
believing their own press notices
um
and that's what we that's what we see
i don't know if that's the answer to
your question but i like saying it
we have a question way in the back
hi
ben boychuk
um
you're a connoisseur of the confidence
man you've given us some of the great
confidence men
in theater and in film
jimmy dell is one of my favorite
confidence men because you made steve
martin a villain
i wonder
as you look upon the political scene
today
how do you assess
president obama as a confidence man in
the panoply of confidence men
and
not to put a fly in the ointment but how
do you assess mitt romney as a
confidence man
well i don't know you know i mean they
you know it's like they say they're
going to work their side of the street
and and i'm going to work mine i heard
condoleezza rice talk about
several weeks ago and someone said oh my
god you know dr weiss you're so
brilliant so funny you're so smart
you're so patriotic why don't you run
for president she said i just don't have
it in me she said i used to tour with
george bush and at the end of the day he
was raring to go and the end of the day
i was raring to shoot myself
so there are these people in our evolved
system who spend
their whole life
doing press
and begging and they're called
politicians and once in a while a public
servant
we get one who also has the capacity to
be a public servant and has a little
time left over at the end of the day
between lying and begging to take to
take care of the to take care of the
country
and as as milton friedman said we just
don't have the time to
bone up on the people who are trying to
rob us through the ex-corporation the
people are trying to rob us through the
y union and the people who are getting a
subsidy for this and the people are
getting a substitute for that because we
think about it for 10 seconds a year and
they think about it all day every day so
there's only one thing that we can do
and that's to cut taxes and slash the
size of the government but and that
because you know who
who knows if who knows if they're a
confidence man
i i don't know you know i met mitt
romney i like him very much i like
everything ever did i shook his hand you
know on the other hand i grew up i
actually grew up and was born on the
south side of chicago where obama claims
to come from and was born in hyde park
and i saw that whole
that whole substratum of i see
everything through that uh through
through that of course they're all
confidence man next question
[Music]
[Applause]
uh we have a question here
well uh glenn garrick and ross is
reopening i gather in revival with al
pacino playing a different role uh your
uh your great and striking plays are
rather cynical about american capitalism
and
no great problem there interestingly
harold pinter a great left winger his
great play seemed to have nothing to do
with his political message but as a
great artist uh who's written some great
plays do you see yourself evolving in
some way
that in some way
the way you articulate your politics and
your view of culture is going to be
incorporated in your art in
in some way well i don't think any of my
plays are political i certainly hope
they aren't and also i don't think
harold's plays were political you know
he wrote a couple of short overtly
political plays late in life mountain
language and a couple of others but his
plays were just yummy
and i don't think it's the place of the
theater to be political you know it's
i shouldn't even be here tonight
actually you know
um
was i critical of capital i don't know
if i was critical of capital i was
driving a cab at the time i wrote most
of those early plays and i'm not driving
a camera anymore and so
you know i see if you're writing the
same the same play at 65 as you were at
19 you're doing something wrong
[Music]
i saw heather higgins raise her hand so
why don't we get a microphone tour
thanks very much um when you talk about
the doubt that is being suppressed
by courage and belief
and you have now come out of the
political closet
what are the doubts that you find are
the most fertile ground for you when
you're talking with your colleagues
trying to persuade them to perhaps have
the same epiphanies that you have had
what are the arguments that you find the
arguments that i find about what ma'am
the arguments that i find about what
when you're trying to explain your
political transition and the
understandings that you now have that
you didn't used to have
what where are the greatest doubts where
is it that you have the greatest success
in in trying to persuade others to see
the world as you now see it
i i can't persuade anybody i don't have
that power i mean i certainly wouldn't
attempt it in the play and
the only people i ever talked to are
conservatives i mean you know is there
any liberals here tonight you're lost
you're in the wrong room
um i don't try to persuade any i don't
try to persuade anybody i'll tell you
what i met um my first
conservative was a friend of a friend
and i didn't i never met a conservative
in my life
and uh i was impressed by him because he
answered questions he was very composed
and he was very patient and he was very
simple and he wasn't rancorous and he
tried to uh
gauge his responses to the level of my
request and he was very welcoming and
over the course of a year i thought i i
don't understand anything this guy's
saying but he's so damn polite
that maybe maybe i shouldn't maybe i
shouldn't maybe there's something in his
convictions it's like the old uh
argument between the two great rabbis
hillel and shamai and the talmud gave
the the uh they retired the cup and gave
it to hillel not because his argument
was was better but because he was more
polite to shamai i don't think that one
i don't think that i i really think
that breaking free of the bubble
is a terrible terrible heart i think
it's breaking free of the addiction of
thought and it starts in the public
schools and it starts in the private
schools and it starts in in one half of
the of the media and it's dreadfully
hard to break especially as our country
uh of spreads itself into political uh
enclaves but one goes through one's
whole life not never meeting a
conservative or never meeting a liberal
if you're in the if if if you're in the
other camp so any of us who've had the
wonderful experience of trying to con
convince a liberal by reason
uh have come to
appreciate the value of a trip to the
dentist
can we we have a question over in the
corner
david deroser um i'm a big fan of
glengarry glen ross particularly the
opening scene where the compensation
structure is laid out so first prize
cadillac second prize set of steak
knives third prize you're fired i'm i
think what you gave tonight was a a
cadillac of a of a speech albeit a a
black cadillac one that might you know
go in the front procession of a funeral
um
is there anything that you might be able
to tell us i mean particularly you know
i accept your diagnosis and your
prognosis but could you give some
mammoth speech into what we could do to
actually keep this experiment and
self-government going maybe even as you
ended your last statement about how we
can start an education how how do you
start an education
yeah i mean i go through it all day i uh
my wife and i got a 13 year old at home
and you got to sit and then we're taking
them out of that school
and trying to find a some school that's
not uh uh
not in the pod
i think it's important to tell the truth
i don't think that one has to be
politically confrontational i don't
think that it's productive and i know
and i don't think it's polite but i
think once in a while when it it when
it's when we have the opportunity
perhaps if someone comes to us
and says you know what would you explain
your positions to me to as i'm sure all
of you do who happen to be conservative
say sure i'd be happy to please tell me
where i'm wrong
i think other than that i don't know
what we can do because i mean all you
know i haven't slept in the last two
years i don't know if anybody here has
and you know
it's enough already and i don't think
it's the most important election since
1980 i think it's the most important
election since 1860 i really do
[Applause]
okay
avec roy there and then we'll get the
other question in the middle there
that's
why aren't there why aren't there more
conservative playwrights and uh is there
anything that can be done about that or
is that essential
is that just inherent to the human
condition and the nature of playwriting
well you well here's the thing you can't
breed playwrights you really can't i
mean you know i knew joe papp who was a
knew him very very well was a great
wonderful guy the biggest con man who
ever lived and he kept he kept shaking
down the state and the government and
the rich people anybody would listen and
he did a hamlet with eskimos you know
and uh he did the women with an
all-female cast you know he did ever
ever he would just do any goddamn thing
he didn't care but the politic that's
not the place for politics and
unfortunately the contemporary theater
comes out of the university system
you know i was very fortunate william h
macy and me and joe mantegna and a whole
bunch of people and
william peterson and dennis franz and
all these guys we were all kids in
chicago 22 years old we had our own
theater companies we didn't we didn't
know any better we made it up as we went
along but kids nowadays i don't i think
that they're doing that on the internet
and doing it on them twitting you know
whatever the hell they do but they don't
but
they they they study the theater and
awarded for doing the theater in
universities which are all the liberal
arts uh
universities are completely democratic
and so the kids rather than having the
experience of the free market
which me and macy and billy peterson for
you know franz and farina had you got to
please the audience who they ain't
coming back tomorrow have the the
unfortunate experience of growing up
trying to please the teacher
right which is you can't and that's not
theater and so they grow up because
that's where the playwrights come from
then they come to new york and so you
have your your pick of affliction plays
you know who's going to be in the barrel
this season so we can you know we can
come out humming the fact that xyz are
people too and feel good about ourselves
you got to have a place you've got to
have a place to go to have a place to
fail
i'll tell you a really good clue you
have a look at somebody's resume and you
say they won the following play
competitions xyz you don't have to read
their place they can't write
we had a question there yes just uh just
to follow up on that i would love to get
your opinion on the work of your new
york times esteemed colleague tony
kushner
you know tony kushner is going to work
his side of the street and i'm going to
work mine we have very different he's a
very good writer he's a very good writer
we have very different political we have
very very different political views
you know he's that's the great thing
about free speech you know it let's
[Music]
i get the right
to to put on my plays if i can find
enough suckers you know to invest in
them and so does he
and some of them are in the audience
like yes and i'm glad i said it
okay
you know we'll let you know we'll we'll
let it let fight it out
we'll fight it out you know and
posterity will be its own judge and what
will it mean to all of us will all be
gone big deal
okay is then the question in the middle
there somehow
yeah right
why don't you grab that
hi my name is phil mills um an actor and
i was just uh i was really interested in
what you were saying about
we humans as social animals and about
excommunication and i was wondering if
you had had your um
i guess intellectual conversion earlier
in life before you were less established
and
a little bit older would you have been
more reticent to be vocal about it
um or you know in in you better
yeah
okay good to know
you know i i i'm pretty arrogant but i
don't think i'm stupid
[Laughter]
that's a different thing you know
somebody coming up and he got a family a
wife or husband a kid to support and
they could
uh sometimes you gotta
look at the uh
the jewish tradition says the law the
law of the land is the law so so
sometimes it's a good idea to keep your
head down and sometimes it's not and is
it true that i had uh enjoy a position
such that i felt
immune to a certain amount of uh
of harmful criticism
yeah that is true and had it happened
earlier i don't know it's a an excellent
question thank you
uh
question back here in the center yeah
quick quick question uh do you have a
community organizer and if so do you
know what his name is
i i couldn't absolutely no i would you
repeat the question the question is do
you do you have a community organizer
and if so do you know what his name is
a community organizer and do you know
what his name is
do i have a community organizer listen a
community organizer well you know i grew
up and all my parents knew solinski and
all those sololinsky lights and the
woodlawn organization in hyde park a
community organized just in the name for
a thug that's all a community level has
anyone ever read have you read the works
of saul lelinski reverely for reveling
for radicals what's the other one
there's two thoughts about radicals
and also to
the young actor over there you know also
i realize it's not my job to walk on a
set and say all you brain-dead liberals
over here have you not read frederick
hayek
you know so the people are going to be
talking about the water cooler so big
deal let him talk
one last question here yeah one last
question yeah can you tell us about your
new play the anarchist
can you tell us about your new play the
anarchist yeah oh good i got a new play
it's uh
it's
the anarchist
and uh
[Applause]
and howard kagan and uh jeffrey richards
who here tonight producer god bless you
and it's it's a play about it's kind of
a pastiche of uh
of
patty lupone plays a weather man one of
the bombers you know one of those
killers from the you know bill ayers for
example bernadette door and angela davis
all of those are wonderful political
icons who are now teaching in our uh
higher education but she plays kind of a
an amalgam of us perhaps not quite kathy
boudine but maybe uh um
what was it there was another woman who
just got caught after 30 years and
susan something brother she went back in
the joint and
so she's or or one of the better meinhof
women so patti lupone plays one of these
women who was a terrorist and she's been
in jail and she's up for a parole parole
hearing and the person who's been a
parole officer for 30 years played by
deborah winger is interrogating her
trying to make up her mind whether to
let her go or not and i i think it's
pretty cute you know it's all about
i mean you're going to leave you know
humming selections from lombroso and
marx
and who could ask for anything more
thank you very much thank you
for more information visit the author's
website davidmamet.com